c'est cela la slow démocratie la
réhabilitation des nations démocratiques
dans la mondialisation
l'aménagement d'îlots de décélération
face à l'accélération et à l'extension
sans limites du domaine de la
marchandise
[Musique]
si nous voulons sortir par le haut des
crises de la mondialisation qui se
multiplient ces dernières années et dont
le corps n'a virus c'est finalement le
dernier avatar nous avons besoin d'états
nations fort mon livre c'est en quelque
sorte un clin d'oeil à ce mouvement
admirable qui est né en italie dans les
années 1990 et qui consiste à dire que
nous avons besoin d'un véritable
mouvement civique d'un véritable élan
républicain pour retrouver une autonomie
dans la vie politique qu'elles ne soient
pas soumises en quelque sorte aux
dictats permanent des marchés mondiaux
et à cette espèce de course à l'échalote
et d'accélération permanente qui les
imposent est à retrouver en quelque
sorte les joies d'une délibération
démocratique
[Musique]
la crise économique et financière de
2008 dont nous payons encore aujourd'hui
la facture puisque même si des mesures
très fortes ont été prises pour sauver
les économies en particulier grâce à
l'action des banques centrales les
effets sur la société notamment sur les
sociétés occidentales ont été durables
et douloureux
[Musique]
oui j'ai de nombreuses sources
d'inspiration évidemment fernand braudel
m'inspire énormément sa capacité à
réfléchir à ce qu'est le temps de la
politique par rapport à ce qu'est le
temps de l'économie à articuler sa
réflexion à différentes échelles aussi
je pense que c'est un auteur extrêmement
important pour moi je suis aussi très
influencé par le philosophe américain
michael walser qui est un philosophe
républicain nous devons inventer un
nouveau mode de collaboration si j'ose
dire entre un capitalisme de plus en
plus mondialisé et une démocratie qui
persistent à se vivre et à s'exercer
dans les états nations
[Musique]